es una medida que para muchos resulta
polémica pero teniendo en cuenta que el
Gobernador es el republicano ron de
santis podemos decir que era algo que se
esperaba y también hay algo que aún se
puede hacer para revertirla yo creo que
para revertirla no todavía en este
momento Valentina buenas noches
recordemos que en este momento la la el
Capitolio en en Florida está dominado
por los republicanos Entonces el primero
de julio será esta esta ley ya una una
legalidad digo para que la puedan hacer
Bueno y realmente la normativa elimina
todos los controles a quienes porten
armas de fuego
no No necesariamente los controles o sea
porque Mira ya en este momento hay tres
millones de personas que tienen licencia
para llevar un arma oculta Y si bien va
a ser obligatorio todavía un permiso y
espera de tres días Sí algunas cosas van
a se van a digamos facilitar para esas
compras directas de de las armas que van
a usar de manera oculta
Bueno y cómo se puede analizar a gran
escala el impacto de esta iniciativa
teniendo en cuenta el elevado número de
tiroteos registrados en Estados Unidos
en los últimos años mira lo que hay que
entender es que el 96% de esos tiroteos
han sido con armas ilegales solo el
cuatro por ciento con con armas
registradas entonces la idea de que el
estado puede subir las acciones en
cuanto a otros ataques masivos o ataques
directos con armas yo creo que no va a
ser así porque si no otros estados
tuvieran esa misma acción Me parece que
lo que está haciendo Es que la población
esté relativamente sintiéndose más
segura pero no subiendo el riesgo de que
puedan haber más actos Como esos